[Musica]
di dover venuto anch'io sarò giovanna
frega se ne accorga natale di varese e
il commercio cecilia cose poi
attivista di fatah
milano quindi partiamo subito
da te
fotogrammi di essere con noi
scusate ciao anzi
direi partire dall altra storia per
portarci due parole ci seri ma
soprattutto come deciso di diventare un
atto di fede fra le sportive
allora io non ho 18 anni ho finito
quest'anno le scuole superiori e ho
sempre avuto una visita una sensibilità
personale perché sociali politici sono
curioso una persona empatica quindi
però la prima volta che ho sentito del
movimento ambientalista che si andava
formando è stata quando avrei parlato
meno che non ha mai avuto a che fare con
i movimenti ambientalisti che non è un
giovane ora vanno avanti quindi qualche
anno fa giocar bene
era l'anno in cui viveva iniziava a
protestare e questa cosa lo ha colpito
così tanto e altra questo episodio di
prendervi da parte letteralmente di fare
un discorso serio
io credo abbiamo fatto esattamente la
stessa
che ci piace questa ragazza svezia che
ogni venerdì
il futuro perché se temesse il rischio
della crisi climatica e proprio detto
devi fare qualcosa anche
questa è la cosa che
ma è un problema
quindi quando è stato chiamato il primo
grado globale vittima ci sono andata e
mi ha colpito tantissimo perché in una
cosa enorme ed è la prima volta piede
della nostra generazione che non ero
magari così abituati alla politica si
sono sentite chiamate in causa per la
prima volta e anche se magari quell'età
non capisci l'enormità di quello che
stai affrontando comunque non sei così
ti dà
emotivamente
molto
linea della scuola almeno ormai proprio
conto curate cioè di capire che i vostri
progetti
mistici milano e questa opportunità è
arrivata poi con il compito in realtà
durante la pandemia
ho saputo delle piegate presentate per
l'emergenza e quindi con altri studenti
mi sono messo a fare volontariato
questo è stato il riallaccio con il
mondo della politica conosciuto
attivissimi fare semplice milano e
l'unità quel momento è la seconda ondata
è una cosa quindi i primi mesi tra i
destini stati da remoto concetto di
stili lo sapevo che quello che faccio
avessero il santo occupato
prevalentemente dei social
e sono proprio vissuto la potenza del
movimento in prima persona per
carotenuto i dettagli critico invece il
punto tc questo movimento per te a quel
grande e potente
puoi adattarci in breve la portata
globale la fiducia lo farebbe
il fenomeno molto particolare perché è
diventato un movimento visto proprio
baldini giro di niente alla fine della
quale 18 30 contestato da sola è stata
seguita rivolta da vari altri paesi nel
giro di mesi e fumare 7 primi 19 si
chiamava già abbiamo solo globali
diritti cui hanno partecipato quindi 100
paesi per un totale di circa 1.700 shop
e nei locali di è un aumento enorme ad
essere molto sfaccettato sicuramente
qualcosa di mai visto prima nella storia
dell'umanità
al momento così abile così provare e
angelo rapporto l'autostrada proprio
nella scientifica puoi raccontarci anche
su questo o la vostra posizione
ha portato a tutte e tentazioni mia
gestione delle richieste che in rete è
stato dice si va da 1 a 100 per cento su
fatti scientifici oggettivi e siamo
supportati al cento per cento dalla
comunità scientifica ad esempio più
eclatante quando nell'aprile 2019 sulla
rivista science è stato pubblicato un
articolo scritto dalla comunità
scientifica con il piccolo le
preoccupazioni degli attivisti sono qui
per giustificate l'articolo potuto
spiegata e tutte le rivendicazioni né
richiesti fridays sono supportati da
un'unione sempre disponibile questo è
stato firmato da più di 3 mila
scienziati
quindi sul mantenere sempre molto in
fretta un momento a suo modo molto
possiamo dire che si faccia una scienza
e che cerca di essere molto coerente
queste stesse mi sto un po da fuori vai
a votarci
interna quale la lastra disegno
complessivo e inserite le vostre reti
nazioni
siano un po di punti solo la sindone poi
ovviamente sono tutti con nek si
ricollega leoni quello che ho detto
prima
ovviamente parlando tutti gli attivisti
su fatti oggettivi
che soprattutto movimenti completamente
orizzontale che giustamente non c'è
nessuno che anche peggio del solito un
altro
opinioni e allo stesso tempo però al
movimento enorme che non prendo un sacco
di persone di paesi e culture diverse e
quindi con voci niente diverse poi con
tutti molto importanti sulla rete
climatica e perché queste sono collegati
a nessuno primo la crisi climatica non è
qualcosa che succederà in un futuro
apocalittico la crisi climatica e adesso
per esempio quelli che inneggiano alle
persone e in paesi e sono a serio
rischio della crisi climatica si stanno
ascoltando con le catastrofi che
derivano da essa in questo momento
questo tema molto sentito da fra i nets
per esempio alla politica devastata
grema non ha parlato fuori dal vertice
per far emergere le due voci non è stata
inizi e di tutti gli attivisti attivisti
paesi posti papa agli attivisti indigeni
e inoltre secondo questo è comunque
collegato la crisi private amici
colpisce tutti allo stesso modo come si
suol dire che forse nella società
tempesta ma non siamo tutti nella stessa
barca
crisi climatica i giusti tra soci crisi
sociale sono fortemente collegate e
tutti siamo colpiti dallo stesso modo
per questo le voci tutto parlavo prima
degli alpinisti più colpiti e anche per
i svantaggiati a prescindere da questo
vanno ascoltate e più di altre sono più
di altri però ne va dato una calmata già
speso e
terzo
noi pensiamo che le penne individuali
sia molto importante ma
quello che bisogna richiedere è un
cambiamento
tematico per cui il singolo è troppo
debole e qui ci serve un gruppo da qui
deriva anche poi aveva fatto aprile con
questo cambiamento climatico crisi
climatica che è primo
chiude selettivo e secondo più corretto
una crisi
di certo cambiamento sistematico per
poterla risolvere e poi non è molto
popolare
molti poi di sé
l'effetto più eclatante della crisi
climatica non c'è
richiedere una situazione
del tutto grazie poche parole hai
raccontato già veramente tanto e
insomma tv reti fondamentali e quella
che emerge l'altra racconta che per
essere appunto convinto molto globale e
poco tempo fa settembre a milano
ospitata l'altro è cotto quindi la pre
conferenza della coop e tratte per
questo momento tra fc il milan ospitato
attivisti internazionali
nel mondo sono venute milano
a protestare a portare avanti alle
astrazioni vuoi raccontarci qualcosa di
base esperienza in particolare del qb
conosciuto da vicino a monte prima del
discorso di giovedì
3 comodo la prova dei giovani sono
queste contenente di preparazione che si
sono appunto tenuto a milano e abbiamo
avuto l'opportunità di conoscere 17
visti per nazionali in diretta e vanessa
ed è stato un momento che ti arricchisce
ci ha arricchito tantissimo
perché ogni attivista delle lotte
personali delle motivazioni personali
che la spinge all'azione e questo è un
mondo molto interconnesse perché nel
mare un filo rosso che ci collega se
questo è molto bello
per fare un esempio un attivista dello
zimbabwe della vigilia tipo raccontare
nella città di distanza capitolo
liberato
distruggano sbaglia dunque dire e come
lei protestanti questo senso io
attivista italiano di persona accordare
ho fatto davanti a quella multinazionale
peso dice
spinge
insomma vocali
questo è molto bello e
sono cose magari ogni però te ne accorgi
quando parli con la gente cioè voce
delle persone sono la cosa più
importante
la porta nel mio piccolo e
bisogna accorgersene
queste interazioni con persone fuori
dalla realtà ci sono anche capire magari
meglio il nostro punto di vista so che
fare delle riflessioni dell'ottocento
sento di dire che cosa questo abbia
significati diversi contesti diversi
sì questo mi ricorda qualcosa
un attivista che abbiamo incontrato una
ragazza grande ente che anche detto
comunque un privilegio poter combattere
per la giustizia climatica
perché se stai morendo di fame stai
cercando del cibo
il contratto per la crisi climatica
anche se magari
è fatta
stiamo per questo ho detto caro
contratti di programma mi ha fatto molto
capire il privilegio
io ho deve essere data a un certo che
noi certo in un certo luogo e quindi gli
insorti
io da una voce che posso usare
collegiata e non ho altri problemi
problemi più grandi
passate ministri
usare e quindi credo che sia importante
che io con la mia voce
io per parlare appunto di tutte le
missioni due privilegiate usiamo la
nostra posizione anche per far emergere
le voci
appunto chi non può farlo per esempio
molti
attivisti di paesi mestre rischio non
sono riusciti ad aggiungere della coop
non potevano vaccinarsi e quindi le loro
voci non sono nemmeno riuscita a
raggiungere l'asilo concesso quelle più
importante di tutti e noi abbiamo una
grande festa
verità che ne viva del nostro secondo me
è importantissimo siamo per far emergere
dopo cina
poter raccontare
non lo vediamo ma in questo momento
troppo del mondo spiace prima di mamma
lacrima di calabria ora ci sono
costantemente stanno mi stanno scoprendo
il tema della situazione così pesante
la speranza è importante per voi siete
attivisti quindi credete fermamente di
poter cambiare il mondo
cosa significa per la speranza non la
vive
se
pensassero che certi sperata da sun e
nemmeno qui a parlare come vi sia
assolutamente quando quest'estate è
uscito il timore della disse sì
sono sfruttate intestati alla
strettamente incanta strato comunque cs
passato conteneva di sentiremo un altro
dal nostro tutto ballottata sia di
totale ma lì non fiatano
inutilmente e fredde superficie l'italia
ha fatto una piccola campagna
[Musica]
questa linea di pensiero
c'è speranza è questa non è una nostra
convinzione è mai quel che dice la
scienza in quel modo ma se ti fa ancora
qualcosa destro
che fatica
potranno non essere divertiti
reversibili quindi di soluzioni ci sono
e della bisogna inventarsi niente
davvero le soluzioni ci sono passano tre
mesi
quindi in questo senso c'è un sacco di
spazio per agire bisogna far ricordare
il vero e lo stesso fa ora
detto semplicemente essere passati
quindi la speranza
quindi sono il vostro movimento a una
grande consapevolezza politica sta
cercando di agire in un modo se questo
articolo non siete semplicemente la
sfortuna madonna una certa visione eh si
non siamo come magari è facile generale
dei giornali ragazzi settimane per me è
importantissimo stato gli ex delineare
quello che facciamo noi e politica siamo
consapevoli
soluzioni che possono esserci
pretendiamo che queste
vengono prese in linea con
assolutamente
ok ultima cosa dopo riempito la testa
simile stime sui riflette ed è che
messaggio con italiana ed artistiche
sono in moto noi oggi in che modo ti
auguri colore riescono a vivere queste
200 giorni
credo che noi che nei sentiste
consapevoli in molti sensi anche
davanzati errori il secondo me è
importantissimo nelle facciate molto
stesso prima di tutto consapevoli che
come artisti avete vedere di raggiungere
sacco di poter aggiungere un sacco di
persone a livello
quindi essere consapevoli questo
essere consapevoli di tutto del problema
che c'è
essere consapevoli che ci sono delle
questo problema
essere consapevoli che queste soluzioni
vanno prese alla iii è cosa troppo tardi
e
si rende finiti ma comunque essere
consapevoli che lo spazio per l'azione
quindi sì secondo me è la consapevolezza
in tutti questi sensi e
se vi dovevo dire
grazie mille
lasciamo adesso sotto linfatico altro
catelli nella scrittura prossimo
prossima sessione dire che ci stai
facciamo ne abbiamo parlato prima
pensando alla saggezza 10 che dimostrano
di aver capito tante cose di oggi nella
forza la voglia di chi pretende di
queste cose sulla taglia capite per le
trattative ricordarci sempre quello che
sappiamo e cosa semplice ma potentissima
e tornava in mente un po per
contrapposizione marche pensi nella
sostanza di pensiero quello che diceva
david h all la coop 27 milan esce di
giorni fa mi raccontava dalla fine
dell'ascoli nissim a e bellissima vita a
95 anni che ha assistito al declino
delle miss istigati chiude la natura in
quest'ultimo secolo è però dice va
dicendo si augura masi chiedendo
pretendendo le nuove generazioni e
essere coloro che invece saranno
testimoni della rinascita della natura
della rinascita del rapporto tra
ambiente e dunque a studiare che li
lasciamo a voi lavorate da parte mia e
lascio fare ad altri
[Applauso]
[Musica]